[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
28 juin l'intervention policière de
Nanterre n'était manifestement pas
conforme aux règles Elisabeth borne a
réagi à la mort de Naël en tirant les
leçons de la vidéo accablante pour les
forces de l'ordre Emmanuel Macron parle
de son côté d'un acte inexplicable et
inexcusable et ça provoque la colère de
certains syndicats de policiers
demandent que la présomption d'innocence
soit respectée quant aux maires de
Nanterre il appelle au calme
arrêtons cette spirale destructrice
protégeons nos quartiers nos biens
communs qu'ensemble nous avons eu tant
de mal à construire et à rénover comment
éviter de nouvelles émeutes faut-il
revoir la loi qui régit l'usage des
armes par les policiers et les gendarmes
on en débat juste après ces titres et
puis tout à l'heure c'est dans le monde
de l'espionnage que je vous emmène
plusieurs experts internationaux
affirment que la guerre en Ukraine a
ouvert une nouvelle
ère une décennie des espions quelles
sont les moyens notamment technologiques
des services de renseignement quel est
le profil des agents secrets les Alliés
2020 la France a-t-elle les moyens de se
protéger efficacement ne ratez pas
l'analyse et les récits de nos invités
dans 45 minutes
mais d'abord on remonte le fil de cette
journée ou après la mort d'un adolescent
de 17 ans tu es sous les tirs d'un
policier l'émotion est monté jusqu'au
sommet de l'État Audrey
le drame de Nanterre interpelle jusqu'au
sommet de l'État ce midi Emmanuel Macron
a interrompu quelques minutes son
déplacement à Marseille pour évoquer la
mort de Naël 17 ans tué lors d'un
contrôle de police nous avons un
adolescent qui a été tué cette
inexplicable une excusable et d'abord je
ce sont des mots d'affection de peine
partagée de soutien à sa famille et à
ses proches ensuite la justice a été
immédiatement saisie je souhaite qu'elle
fasse son travail
avec évidemment célérité et dans le
calme ce travail requiert un appel au
calme après une nuit de tension de
violence et d'affrontement
entre des jeunes et les forces de
l'ordre dans plusieurs villes de la
banlieue parisienne un embrasement
déclenché par la mort de l'adolescent
quelques heures plus tôt la scène a été
filmée par un passant on y voit deux
policiers arrêtés la voiture jaune de
Naël qui circule sans permis mise en
jour par l'un des agents il redémarre
avant d'être touché mortellement et à
bout portant au thorax interpellé par
trois fois par la gauche sénatoriale
l'émotion est très vive dans le pays
j'ai mal à ma France à titré à tweeté
Killian Mbappé disant avec ces mots ce
que ressentent je crois des millions de
jeunes et de parents le gouvernement et
la première ministre décrivent une vidéo
choquante les images choquantes
diffusées hier montre une intervention
qui ne semble manifestement pas conforme
aux règles d'engagement de nos forces de
l'ordre la droite quant à elle appelle à
ne pas jeter l'eau propre sur toute la
police je vois bien que et notamment à
gauche à l'extrême gauche surtout on
tente de passer du procès d'un policier
au procès de toute la police ou bien
d'un certain nombre de modalités de
doctrine d'emploi des âmes je pense
qu'on en est pas là s'il y a eu une
faute grave elle est de toute façon très
grave par ses conséquences il faudra une
sanction une sanction très très ferme le
policier auteur du tir est actuellement
en garde à vue pour homicide volontaire
la famille de Naël de son côté
oui parce que les images qu'on a vu sont
des images qui sont troublantes qu'il
faudra d'ailleurs corréler avec des
idées d'autres images je ne sais pas si
c'est policier portait sur eux la caméra
piéton dont les législateur a permis et
qu'ils doivent normalement porter je
sais pas si ils ont une limite sont des
motards donc je ne sais pas si c'était
le cas si vous êtes allumé et si les
images ont été saisis en tous les cas où
évidemment rien ne justifiait que ce que
ce jeune soit tué mais je vois trois je
vois trois moments il y a un moment de
l'arrestation au star du moment où le
véhicule est arrêté c'est un jeune qui
conduit sans permis un véhicule qui est
une grosse cylindrée et on voit sur les
vidéos le les policiers le tenir en
jouent pourquoi donc ça c'est l'enquête
interne pénale j'imagine aussi l'enquête
disciplinaire parce qu'il y aura deux de
deux enquêtes parallèles qui vont qui
vont être conduites il y a ensuite le
délit de fuite avec un tir et le modules
qui va s'arrêter quelques centaines de
mètres plus tard et puis il y a tout ce
qu'on vit depuis ce moment une très
grande émotion dans le pays puisque il y
a eu un décès d'un jeune et puis une
situation très compliquée hier soir à
Nanterre qui qui fait que les
responsables politiques dont je fais
partie doivent appeler au calme au
respect du temps du deuil pour la
famille évidemment aussi au respect de
l'enquête judiciaire et des grands
principes il y a un principe un autre
pays qui s'appelle la présomption
d'innocence il est applicable à ces deux
policiers évidemment et et un temps
aussi de débat politique qui va s'ouvrir
puisque de ce qui s'est passé nous
devons sans doute tirer un certain
nombre de conscience d'ailleurs déjà
ouvert on a eu beaucoup de réactions et
on en citera quelques-unes dans ce dans
ce débat Maggie la Fourcade au-delà de
l'émotion qu'elles le sont vous tirer de
ce qui s'est passé alors moi je crois
qu'effectivement la première leçon c'est
la retenue et le sens du deuil et de
l'émotion qui envoie dans les paroles
politiques parce qu'on n'a pas toujours
eu ce phénomène là et là je trouve que
toute la classe politique s'est mis en
ordre de marche pour pouvoir avoir un
discours cohérent et qui est respectueux
donc loin de d'une criminée des nations
de la victime ce qu'on a pu commencer à
percevoir au début de la séquence donc
là dans la réaction d'un syndicat de
police
un tout petit peu plus de 3 % d'heure du
coup les mauvais souvenirs de 205 et je
pense que l'enjeu il est aussi de
d'ordre public et de respect des
individus dans une des quartiers
populaires c'est-à-dire de ne pas
susciter l'embrasement en ayant un
cadrage politique et médiatique qui ne
soit pas
coordonnées cohérent avec la réalité des
faits ça c'est la première chose mais
quand j'entends un responsable politique
dire faut pas faire le procès de la
police non mais il faut pas non plus
considérer que c'est de ce sont des cas
qui sont absolument isolés d'une
personne qui aurait éventuellement mal
agi avec bien sûr le principe de respect
de la présomption d'innocence qui est
absolument cardinal il faut quand même
aussi analyser les causes structurelles
et le fait que il y a eu quand même une
multiplication par 5 du nombre de
personnes tuées dans le cadre des des
une obtempérer depuis la loi 2017 alors
ça on y reviendra en détaillera ce qui
était effectivement la loi 2017 à
l'époque c'était Bernard Cazeneuve qui
était ministre de l'Intérieur Sonia
fibloy les réactions politiques on y
reviendra mais est-ce que vous jugez
vous aussi quels ont été mesurées ou
est-ce que vous craignez justement ce
moment-là qui s'amorce depuis quelques
heures de récupération je mets des
guillemets ou de combat politique autour
de ce qui s'est passé à Nanterre tout
d'abord on s'associe évidemment à
l'émotion qui est provoquée par les
images évidemment par les conséquences
dramatiques de ce qui s'est passé on a
une pensée évidemment pour pour la
famille pour ses proches maintenant nous
avons une enquête qui est en cours et je
comprends qu'il y a le temps de
l'émotion que nous vivons actuellement
aujourd'hui et cette nuit également la
nuit dernière et puis le temps de
l'enquête et qui n'est pas ni le temps
médiatique ni le temps de l'émotion et
qui nous permettra d'y voir un petit peu
plus clair sur les circonstances vous
avez parlé monsieur en amont et sur les
circonstances donc du contrôle routier
et puis sur l'usage de l'arme en
l'occurrence ce qui est difficile pour
je suis d'accord avec vous essayons
collectivement de respecter ce temps
mais les vidéos parce qu'il y en a
plusieurs
un site à apporter un jugement rapide on
va revoir une vidéo et je pense que on
l'a vu dans le sujet mais sans sans ces
images du contrôle routier meurtrier à
Nanterre on aurait ce soir la version
des policiers qui parlent de légitime
défense pour justifier le tir et cette
vidéo il y en a d'autres encore une fois
elle change tout c'est ce que dit
l'avocat de la famille de Naël on
l'écoute tout de suite
c'est une affaire extrêmement grave il y
a donc cette vidéo qui montre clairement
qu'un policier a abattu un jeune homme
de sang-froid aujourd'hui le policier
qui a tiré est en garde à vue nous
souhaitons donc les choses se
poursuivent d'une manière sereine mais
nous serons bien entendu vigilants car
l'homicide volontaire existe dans ce
dossier il n'y a pas de légitime défense
mes clients souhaitent que la loi soit
appliquée et que le policier soit mis en
examen pour homicide volontaire
poursuivi et je pense que je pense que
seul une application stricte de la loi
permettra à la situation de s'apaiser le
kervé ce qu'on voit là c'est que les
enquêteurs ils vont travailler sous
pression ils vont travailler sous
pression populaire il y a le risque des
émeutes sous pression politique les
politiques sont voilà réagissent et
c'est logique c'est normal sous pression
médiatique aussi les médias joueurs rôle
est-ce qu'on peut
espérer une justice sereine dans un
contexte de pression comme celui là
oui parce que nous sommes une démocratie
que nous avons une justice indépendante
et que les magistrats qui vont être en
charge de cette affaire moi je veux bien
que vous qu'on puisse affirmer des
choses comme vous le faites et dire la
vidéo est explicite et donner la parole
à l'avocat d'une des parties en l'espèce
avocat de la famille de la victime mais
en disant voilà la vérité est déjà
établie c'est ce que dit l'avocat le
procureur à l'instant
n'a pas encore pris la parole voilà donc
je voudrais quand même que on respecte
ce temps judiciaire là qui est un temps
judiciaire court on parle pas de
l'enquête et de la d'une éventuelle
incarcération
du contradictoire je parle de l'enquête
immédiate est-ce qu'il y a des images
des de est-ce que c'est policiers portés
des Camara piéton est-ce qu'ils ont des
images est-ce que ce qu'ils ont à dire
écorroborés par des éléments matériels
autre que les vidéos que vous donnez et
la vie du de la famille par exemple on
s'est posé la question hier soir est-ce
qu'il pouvait y avoir par exemple dans
la voiture je pense que si on avait
trouvé des armes on le saurait déjà bah
vous ne le savez pas je ne le sais pas
je voudrais je voudrais pas faire une
faire diversion mais je voudrais vous
parler d'Annecy vous voyez qu'on a quand
les premières réactions sont arrivées
sur ce qui s'est passé à Annecy le
préfet de la Haute-Savoie la procureur
d'Annecy n'avait pas encore pris la
parole que déjà des vérités politiques
étaient assez nées dans les médias en
disant mais vous savez c'est ça c'est un
terroriste etc
gardons-nous tout ça parce que si nous
voulons apaiser la situation ça sert à
rien de faire des commentaires en l'air
alors que nous avons très peu d'éléments
je rappelle que vous êtes sénateurs
d'autres Savoie et donc au coeur de ce
qui s'est passé Maggie votre avis
là-dessus est-ce qu'on va trop vite en
regardant les images de ces vidéos alors
bien sûr qu'on va trop vite en regardant
les images puisque bon moi j'ai été
Jules instruction je peux vous dire que
j'ai rarement retrouvé les dossiers que
j'avais en charge dans quand ils étaient
avec une telle pression médiatique ça se
passe de manière très sereine la justice
on est indépendante etc non c'est plutôt
que ce qui est restitué dans les médias
est loin de la vérité des dossiers donc
il faut savoir me faire regarder il faut
boire tout ce qui est possible l'enquête
va être conduite comme on a on sait
qu'on a un policier en garde à vue ça
veut dire que très rapidement puisque la
garde à vue elle a un temps limité dans
la procédure pénale il y aura une
décision d'ouverture d'information
judiciaire puisqu'on est sur un cadeau
éventuellement domicile volontaire donc
c'est criminels donc c'est obligatoire
de saisir un juge d'instruction et à ce
moment-là on saura s'il y a des indices
graves ou concordants laissant présumés
la participation du policier à un
homicide volontaire auquel cas ça
signifie une mise en examen et ensuite
l'enquête se fait pas son cours mais la
pression médiatique
n'entrave pas du tout le rôle d'un juge
d'instruction qui sur des éléments mais
les juges sont humains et ils sont liés
au parquet et on sait que si il y a par
exemple une décision de domicile
involontaire on imagine les conséquences
populaires dans certaines cités là
dans la justice comme ça qui se mène au
long cours avec avec un travail
d'enquête soigneux avec la police
judiciaire etc on n'est pas dans la
recherche de l'émotion et on n'est pas
non plus dans la culture de l'aveu ce
qu'on veut c'est des éléments tangibles
voilà et là on est dans une période où
grâce aux caméras grâce aux vidéos
sauvages qu'on a comme ça mais qui sont
extrêmement instructives le citoyen se
fait son opinion mais le juge aura aussi
des éléments Tangi pour se faire son
opinion donc moi je suis pas inquiète
sur la manifestation de la vérité c'est
ça c'est très important par contre je
suis beaucoup plus inquiète sur le
ressenti par la population locale de la
façon dont ces sujets là sont traités
d'un point de vue avec les conséquences
à moyen et long terme pour la relation
entre ces populations et et la police ce
n'est affiblage je vais pas vous
demander de vous engager sur l'affaire
elle-même mais peut-être sur la
procédure comment ça se passe quand un
policier et mis en cause dans une
affaire comme celle-là il est entendu il
est entendu effectivement par plusieurs
il y a plusieurs procédures en cours
procédure interne externe expliquez-nous
un peu comment ça se passe
tu le dira puisqu'on ne sait pas
actuellement où on est l'enquête et puis
d'autre part l'enquête sur le refus
d'obtempérer commis par l'auteur et ses
co-auteurs qui étaient et qui
l'accompagnait et celui qui est décédé
qui est l'auteur principal de
l'infraction donc deux enquêtes
parallèles que nous menons avec deux
services différents donc des policiers
distincts pour pouvoir établir la vérité
qui est la vérité judiciaire mais je
tiens à rappeler qu'en matière de vérité
judiciaire
chacun a sa vérité si vous voulez nous
avons une vérité qui se fonde sur nos
propres réalités les réalités des
policiers la réalité des magistrats les
réalités des citoyens des réalités des
politiques que nous vivons tous mais la
réalité judiciaire c'est la somme
d'actes objectifs qui sont menées par
les policiers et sous l'autorité des
magistrats et c'est cette réalité
judiciaire infinie qui contrat avec
toujours cette difficulté dont on a
parlé souvent ici de décalage entre de
temps médiatique on veut des réponses
rapides et j'en prends ma part les
journalistes participent de cette espèce
d'urgence mais mais bon c'est aussi
Mathieu je vous vois réagir c'est aussi
une question de pression politique quand
même c'est assez logique quoi question
de temps de médiatique puisque la vidéo
est sur les réseaux sociaux filmé par
quelqu'un qui n'est pas dans les médias
entre guillemets alors les réseaux
sociaux sont des médias et c'était
pareil Annecy c'est à dire qu'on est
tous frappé par des éléments de réalité
qui nous sont présentés sous un certain
angle prix selon un certain point de vue
par une certaine personne à un moment T
et donc après on analyse alors après
cette affaire est compliquée parce qu'il
y a plusieurs logiques qui se percutent
il y a ceux qui veulent comprendre
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec ces deux policiers comment des
policiers en viennent mettre en jeu
comme ça un jeune on ne sait même pas
qui est jeune quand on voit la vidéo
mais un chauffeur et à lui tirer dessus
et ce qu'on est sur un pétage de plomb
individuel le problème c'est qu'ils sont
deux donc deux pétages de plomb ou un
qui arrive pas à calmer l'autre est-ce
qu'on est sur quelque chose de plus
systémique et on en parlera tout à
l'heure sur cette idée qui est déjà
avancée par des politiques
je trouve que l'émotion étant l'émotion
est pas tellement respectée parce que
désir les gens disaient c'est la faute à
la loi de 2017 peut-être est-ce le cas
mais qui en gros aurait instauré une
forme de climat permissivité ou à côté
plus shérif chez les chez les policiers
et puis de l'autre côté il y a il y a
des gens qui veulent comprendre voilà ce
qui se passait dans cette voiture et
c'est l'enquête dont vous parliez sur le
refuge obtempérer qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé et là les avocats de la famille
nous disent non non la vérité elle est
dite par les images il faut pas enquêter
sur le passé du du jeune homme donc on
est on est dans un moment où plusieurs
logiques sociales
ne pètent pas les plombs comme vous
dites les policiers sont des
professionnels qui sont formés et qui
sont aguerris à des situations
difficiles par contre ce sont des êtres
humains qui ont une perception du danger
et on y reviendra pour le cadre
juridique dans lequel nous évoluons
qu'il s'agisse de légitime défense ou de
cette fameuse loi du 28 février 2017
avant son alinéa 4 qui nous est
particulièrement mis sur le devant de la
scène avec cette vidéo mais non non nous
sommes des professionnels et nous
réalisons professionnelle les
professionnels alors cette loi on va en
parler tout de suite je vous donne il y
a deux chiffres qui sur lesquels on va
on va réfléchir ensemble dans ce dans ce
débat celui sur l'usage des armes par
des policiers lors de refusantes tempéré
je vous le propose alors 2022 13
personnes ont été tuées par des tirs de
la police française sur leur véhicule et
vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure c'est une
forte augmentation et puis elle siffle
sur le nombre de refus d'occultants
périphériques et lui aussi en très très
forte augmentation et là c'est sur plus
d'une décennie c'est sur une douzaine
d'années on y reviendra tout à l'heure
mais d'abord effectivement vous en
parliez gros plan sur cette loi de 2017
Samia de chiens vous pouvez nous
rejoindre tout de suite bonsoir Samya et
bienvenue 2017 on peut dire que c'est un
tournant expliquez-nous pourquoi parce
que la loi a changé suite à un événement
en 2016 une voiture de police est
attaquée au cocktail Molotov à
Viry-Châtillon dans l'Essonne quatre
policiers sont à l'intérieur ils
échappent au pire non sans de graves
blessures et là sous la pression des
d'une partie des syndicats policiers une
loi va être adopter un an plus tard pour
assouplir les conditions dans lesquelles
les policiers ont le droit de faire
usage de leur arme en fait avant 2017 il
n'y avait pas vraiment de texte
particulier les concernant seuls la
légitime défense pouvait justifier un
tir policier comme pour presque tout
autre citoyen en fait et depuis 2017 les
policiers sont soumis au même règle que
les gendarmes et elles sont plus souples
c'est règles puisqu'ils peuvent ouvrir
le feu dans cinq situations
identifiées en cas d'atteinte ou de
menaces à leur vie après sommation s'ils
ne peuvent pas se défendre ou protéger
un tiers pour empêcher un meurtre ils
peuvent également tirer pour neutraliser
un individu qui voudrait fuir et qui
pourrait s'en prendre à des tiers dans
cette fuite et enfin peut-être le cas
qui nous intéresse le plus aujourd'hui
Thomas c'est si un refus d'obtempérer de
la part d'un automobiliste et bien peut
menacer physiquement un policier et
depuis on observe une augmentation du
nombre de tirs lors de contrôle routier
oui on va regarder ensemble un graphique
parce est assez parlant il est issu du
rapport de l'IGPN en inspect
l'inspection de la police en 2017 il y a
un véritable bon du nombre de tirs sur
des véhicules en mouvement 202 contre
137 l'année précédente ça fait tout de
même une augmentation de plus de 47 % si
mes calculs sont bons donc plus du
double depuis le nombre de tirs de
nouveau diminué mais avec une moyenne de
150 tirs par an on reste quand même un
niveau qui est plus élevé qu'avant la
loi de 2017 alors on n'a pas de chiffres
plus récents que 2021 sauf peut-être un
bilan que vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure anthona 13 personnes sont mortes
visées par un tir policier à la suite
d'un refus d'obtempérer en 2022 et cette
loi elle est pointée du doigt par
certains qui veulent la changer la
gauche surtout veut revenir sur cette
loi Thomas celle largement occupé les
débats cet après-midi au Sénat lors de
la des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement le sénateur écologiste
tomate bossu a interpellé le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin regardait
leur échange
c'est quoi est manifestement trop
laxiste et la manifestement permis le
développement d'un sentiment d'impunité
qui hier a conduit à un drame monsieur
le ministre si vous voulez que le calme
revienne et nous l'appelons de nos vœux
il est temps de revenir sur cette loi
combien de morts supplémentaires
faudra-t-il pour que vous en preniez
conscience il faut avoir de la dignité
les images que l'on a tous vu ne sont
choquantes parce que ça ne correspond
pas à la loi 2017 loi 2007 que je ne
veux pas ici particulièrement justifié
devant vous n'ayant pas été son auteur
mais surtout trouvant que c'est le temps
du deuil du recueillement et la dignité
républicaine et non de la récupération
politique voilà pour cet échange merci
Samia pour pour toutes ces informations
Loic Hervé a à l'aune de ces
explications de ces chiffres est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut revoir la loi
moi je pense que non je tire pas des
éléments statistiques que vous avez
communiqué les éléments de conséquence
qu'on dit je trouve pas que le que les
chiffres sont aussi éloquents que ça il
y a effectivement un pic en 2017 mais
sinon c'est assez linéaire sans cesse
157 153 bon bref non je pense pas
j'invite d'ailleurs mes collègues
parlementaires qui en ont l'opportunité
de d'aller sur un contrôle routier de la
police gendarmerie pour qu'ils se
rendent compte de ce dont il s'agit je
viens de le faire je l'ai fait il y a
trois semaines ou un mois dans mon
département dans une agglomération avec
un déploiement de contrôle
à l'initiative de la gendarmerie mais
aussi la police de la douane de la
police suisse et vous avez dans la
soirée plusieurs refus d'entrepris en
fait c'est devenu quelque chose de
normal ce qui ce qui était le quelque
chose d'assez logique dans l'éducation
que moi j'ai reçu de s'arrêter
contrôle de police ou de gendarmerie de
présenter ses papiers de faire ce qu'on
nous demande d'être aussi courtois avec
ces fonctionnaires qu'il faut aux
militaires qui font leur travail pour un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens pour
plein de raisons ça c'est pas uniquement
dans le quartier populaire c'est
également dans le monde rural c'est lié
à plein de situations sociales
médico-social vous avez des personnes
qui font demi-tour et qui peuvent
être
en danger les policiers ou les gendarmes
qui sont en train de les contrôler leur
véhicule en armes par destination à
l'égard des mois des fonctionnaires de
police et militaires de la gendarmerie
ou à l'égard de tiers c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait faire demi-tour sur une nationale
la nuit ça peut constituer un danger
pardon de le dire comme ça donc en fait
moi je pense que j'étais rapporteur de
la locmie et j'étais rapporteur de la
loi de sécurité globale et on a eu des
débats notamment avec Gérard Darmanin
sur ces sujets là moi je crois je crois
pas que le problème il soit il soit
législatif pardon de lit je pense qu'il
y a un vrai un vrai problème de la
relation des citoyens ou d'une partie
d'un certain nombre de nos sites
concitoyens à la question de l'autorité
de la police
toujours quelqu'un qui est va dans un
dans le même sens parce que je suis
plutôt un défenseur public mais il y a
pas eu il y a pas une liberté publique
qui permet de refuser un contrôle de
police pardon ça n'existe pas
alors on voit bien ce qui se passe c'est
à dire que refus d'obtempérer la
possibilité avec la loi que les
policiers utilisent leurs armes s'ils
sont mis en danger et et et voilà
largement et c'est alors il y a les
autres éléments mais c'est là que c'est
parfois peut-être compliqué d'ailleurs à
évaluer pour les policiers eux-mêmes je
cherche pas forcément à prendre leur
défense mais est-ce que ça laisse la
place je sais pas à l'arbitraire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de cet
homme moi je vais diverger avec mon
voisin de manière assez nette parce que
la sncdh avait fait une étude au moment
de la loi 2017 de la l'élaboration de la
loi elle est rendu un avis qui a été
publié aux JO qui montre que elle
anticipait des pertes humaines avec ce
texte qui est très rédiger et qui n'est
pas accompagné des garanties autour
parce qu'on peut avoir un texte
législatif qui est assez largement qui
ouvre les autorisations d'engagement de
la force meurtrière de manière assez
large mais qui derrière est accompagnée
d'un encadrement sur le terrain adapté
du fait qu'on n'envoie pas des toutes
jeunes recrues dans les quartiers les
plus compliqués du fait que il y a une
formation au cas de juridique et aux
situations de stress que donc comme vous
le disiez tout à fait les policiers sont
des êtres humains donc ils réagissent
dans une situation donnée donc nous ce
qu'on observe quand même c'est que les
chiffres sont très inquiétants puisque
sur la décennie 2011-2022 depuis 2017
nous avons cinq fois plus de tirs
policiers mortel après un refus d'un
conducteur d'obtempérer en Allemagne sur
cette décennie c'est un mort donc je
veux bien que vous disiez que tout à
l'heure c'était les chiffres des tirs
c'était pas les tirs mortels voilà donc
je veux bien que vous trouviez que ce
soit pas un problème mais il faut
comparer les démocraties libérales il
faut voir par rapport à nos voisins
comment nous travaillons il faut voir
aussi le niveau de défiance que ça
induit donc il y a des effets politiques
il faut traiter ça de manière politique
et donc c'est c'est cette loi elle est
elle est mal accompagnée puisque on
observe une hausse énorme c'est un Cours
des comptes qui le dit en 2000 en 2009
c'était à peu près 46 % des gardiens de
la paix qui se retrouvaient en région
parisienne aujourd'hui c'est 71,5 %.
donc nous avons des jeunes avec un
encadrement intermédiaire qui est très
très saoul sous sous doté pour pouvoir
les encadrer et nous avons des gens dont
la Cour des comptes dit très clairement
que la formation au tir et aux quatre
juridiques du tir est insuffisante donc
avec tous ces éléments là on a une
situation qui peut potentiellement être
explosive et créer des pertes humaines
de manière évidente juste pour le
téléspectateur en l'espèce il s'agit pas
de jeunes recrues ou de jeunes policiers
de ce qu'on a compris puisqu'ils ont
plutôt 38 et 40 ans je passais de police
puisque
c'est important je pense pour éclairer
le débat je suis pas une fan une folle
des chiffres mais notamment les chiffres
les plus récents qui vous manquaient
157 tirs sur les véhicules en mouvement
en 2021 et cette année en 2022 c'est 138
donc on a une tendance légèrement
baissière tout comme nous avons une
tendance baissière contrairement à ce
qu'il dit actuellement sur l'usage de
l'arme du maire générale l'arme
individuel par les policiers puisque
jusqu'en 2019 on était à peu près à plus
de 300 usages de larmes par an et après
2019 nous sommes descendus à moins de
300 et pour vous donner juste les
chiffres les derniers chiffres on était
à 290 en 2021 bon et puis
285 en 2022
et qui comptabilise toutes les usages de
l'arme des policiers donc c'est
extrêmement important de le dire le
comparatif avec une contre démocratie en
occurrence la démocratie allemande
comment vous le comment vous le recevez
ce n'est pas insatisfait site pour nous
parce qu'à partir du moment où déjà il y
a un tir opérationnel c'est forcément
qu'on a été contraint à le faire parce
qu'il faut le rappeler ce cadre
juridique qu'il soit en légitime défense
ou avec la loi 2017 répond à une stricte
proportionnalité et une absolue
nécessité c'est à dire que le policier
perçoit un danger qui est dans ce cadre
de strict proportionnalité et absolue
nécessité donc c'est extrêmement
important de le rappeler maintenant pour
l'analyse du texte de 2017 je pense que
le décorer les juste avec un chiffre de
pique effectivement il y a eu ce pic en
2017 qui est revenu à peu près aux
chiffres un petit peu supérieur mais le
décorer du chiffre de de 13 morts en
2022 lors de l'opération policière de
refuses obtempérer enfin je suis assez
d'accord avec vous pour dire dans une
démocratie moderne on peut pas
satisfaire d'un chiffre comme ça
complètement ce n'est pas du tout mon
propos de me satisfaire de
à gérer et que j'entends les réactions
de la gauche au Sénat aujourd'hui qui
utilise cette situation particulière
alors encore une fois vous n'en
connaissons pas tous les tenants les
aboutissants parce que ça viendrait à
créditer un certain nombre de leur thèse
non je ne crois pas et je pense que pour
en avoir discuté avec eux encore une
fois madame vous représentez la
l'institution policière mais ils
discutant avec les agents de terrain je
les fais je le fais souvent parce que je
m'intéresse à ces questions régaliennes
l'utilisation de l'arme par un policier
ou par un gendarme est une extrémité
c'est la révélation d'un échec et pour
eux-mêmes ils savent très bien que le
simple fait de d'utiliser l'arme
engagera des conséquences énormes à
titre personnel sur en terme de
déroulement de carrière dans le cas de
ça c'est vraiment pardon nous
interrompre
avec une grande démocratie libérale vous
entendez les États-Unis d'Amérique mais
quand même
d'une autre teinture pardon parce que je
parle en même temps vous c'est pas bien
mais un mot de réponse quand même à ce
que disait Magalie la Fourcade tout à
l'heure sur sur le manque d'encadrement
en fait parce que ça c'est une vraie
question pour le législateur et puis
pour le le le gouvernement aussi
évidemment cette loi est-ce qu'elle n'a
pas bénéficié finalement des moyens
nécessaires pour ne pas envoyer je
reprends à peu près aux arguments les
plus jeunes de nos policiers ou non les
moins formés dans des situations les
plus compliquées c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait la locmi c'est pour ça que
les questions de formation d'encadrement
des unités sur le terrain ont été
renforcées ça va produire ses effets
dans les années qui viennent il y a les
fameuses 200 brigades de sur la partie
gendarmerie etc il y a des moyens
supérieurs qui ont été affectés à la
police nationale donc évidemment mais ce
sont des éléments qui sont pour vos
téléspectateurs qui sont pas de
dimensions législatives sont des
dimensions de moyens d'organisation du
ministère de l'intérieur des forces de
sécurité notre pays qui sont voilà mais
est-ce que cette situation là est-ce que
les 13 morts révèlent déficit
d'encadrement des policiers je suis en
incapacité de vous répondre allez
d'autres réactions politiques et d'abord
celles
du chef de l'État Emmanuel Macron l'a
entendu un peu dans dans le sujet
d'ouverture je propose de réécouter donc
il est à Marseille depuis depuis un peu
plus de 2 jours et il réagissait de
là-bas à la mort de Naël écouter d'abord
je veux ici dire l'émotion de la nation
tout entière après donc
ce qui est arrivé
et la mort de du jeune Naël et le dire à
sa famille toutes nos solidarité et
l'affection de la nation nous avons un
adolescent qui qui a été tué cette
inexplicable inexcusable et d'abord je
ce sont des mots d'affection de peine
partagée de soutien à sa famille et à
ses proches ensuite la justice a été
immédiatement saisie je souhaite qu'elle
fasse son travail
avec évidemment célérité et dans le
calme ce travail requiert et que la
vérité puisse être faite dans les
meilleurs délais
et que évidemment nous soyons tous
informés que la justice passe
Mathieu vous avez été frappé par cette
réaction de l'exécutif et notamment du
ministre de l'Intérieur oui parce qu'on
a assisté à une communication en deux
temps en fait avec pour ainsi dire un
sacré changement de ton à l'image de la
réaction du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérard Darmanin il était il y a
interpellé sur ce drame lors de la
séance des questions gouvernement à
l'Assemblée regardez
de très nombreux cas ce sont des
familles de policiers et de gendarmes
qui pleurent leurs enfants alors non
bien sûr le refait nous intérêt ne peut
pas être accepté mais il n'est pas non
plus bien évidemment capable d'accepter
que des policiers tirent à vous pourtant
sur des jeunes hommes ou des jeunes
femmes quel que soit l'âge d'ailleurs
des conducteurs et vous dire qu'on doit
respecter le deuil des familles mais la
présomption innocence des policiers
alors l'effet se sont produits le matin
même et la prudence reste de mise mais
on voit bien l'axe de défense et alors
maintenant parler déjà l'époque d'une
vidéo extrêmement choquante mais c'est
présomption d'innocence et arrow sur les
refus d'obtempérer écoutez-le maintenant
ce matin au côté du préfet de police
je voudrais évidemment d'abord avoir une
pensée bien sûr pour lui pour sa famille
et leur dire bien évidemment que nous
souhaitons au ministère de l'Intérieur
au sein de la police nationale avoir
toute la vérité sur ce qui s'est passé
et en respectant le temps de la justice
le plus rapidement possible donc vous
voyez la parole est beaucoup plus
mesurée émotion et penser pour la
famille ainsi que exigences de vérité
elle parlera aussi pour être complet de
présomption d'innocence vous voyez bien
qu'on n'est pas du tout dans le même axe
c'est plus le même temps pourquoi ce
changement mais parce que l'affaire qui
avait pris des hier à l'Assemblée une
tournure je veux dire parlementaire ou
politicienne et est devenu en tout cas
elle avait revêtu ce matin une dimension
politique et quasi sociétale d'abord à
cause de l'émotion parce qu'on rappelle
que c'est quand même la mort d'un mineur
chaque internaute a pu découvrir la
vidéo on en parlait tout à l'heure puis
il y a eu l'émotion de célébrité on en
parlait aussi
Omar Sy Kylian Mbappe tout ça a sorti ce
drame du seul cercle habituel des
militants contre les violences
policières et puis ce qu'on a ce à quoi
on a assisté cette nuit aussi les scènes
de colère de de de de d'incend de
violence qui ont éclaté dans plusieurs
villes des Hauts-de-Seine on fait tout
ça fait craindre à l'exécutif une
flambée de violence un peu comme celle
que le pays avait connu on va pas faire
le parallèle enfin si vous voyez à quoi
je pense évidemment 2005
Clichy-sous-Bois ou 2016 le décès des
deux jeunes sur une moto percutée par
une voiture de police à Villiers-le-Bel
donc le cocktail Paris c'est si explosif
que Emmanuel Macron et Elisabeth était
quand même très discret hier sont sortis
du du bois aujourd'hui sur ce sujet on a
vu le président de la République on a vu
tout à l'heure ce qu'on pensait Isabelle
borne au Sénat et donc voilà eux aussi
disent leur émotions exige que la
justice soit rendue et on appelle
évidemment au calme et ce qui se joue
dans ce drame c'est aussi le lien entre
la population et la police oui et on
sait que s'il s'agit d'un sujet
extrêmement sensible pour l'exécutif qui
a été très critiqué pour sa gestion du
maintien de l'ordre lors du conflit des
retraites avant cela par les
manifestations qui avaient émaillé vous
souvenez les discussions sur la loi
sécurité globale ou encore avant cela
sur les manifestations des gilets jaunes
en fait l'exécutif n'est jamais parvenu
à trouver de position ferme cohérente
assumée dans le temps sur la question de
ce qu'on appelle les violences
policières pour le ministre de
l'intérieur ça n'existe pas vous
souvenez de cette petite phrase de
Gérard Darmanin quand j'entends le mot
violence policière moi personnellement
je m'étouffe qu'il avait prononcé à
juste après son arrivée à Beauvau c'est
plus compliqué pour Emmanuel Macron hein
candidat en 2017 bah il les dénonçait en
2019 chef de l'État il l'expression
était devenu inacceptable dans un état
de droit pour lui puis il y a eu un
fléchissement fin 2020 devant le média
en ligne brut vous vous souvenez si vous
voulez que je dis je le dis et puis ça a
été de nouveau récusé par ce même
Emmanuel Macron dans la dernière
campagne présidentielle au printemps
2002 dans Le Parisien donc voilà c'est
un impensé politique et en attente ce
qu'il est pose aujourd'hui dans un
problème de communication mais au-delà
bien sûr et on attend de voir comment il
qualifieront le drame d'hier une fois
que l'enquête nous aura dit ce qu'il
s'est passé est-ce que vous employez ce
terme vous policière la sncdh a rendu un
avis qui est une Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme voilà
qui a rendu un ado qui est une
institution indépendante qui a crédité
auprès des Nations Unies et qui a rendu
un avis qui parle de violence policière
illégitime puisqu'il y a aussi des
violences qui sont le monopole de la
violence physique légitime Max Weber
tout ça on connaît bien et là donc il y
a des violences policières illégitimes
qui sont effectivement
on est dans un état de déni alors qu'il
faut traiter ce sujet là et ça
interpelle la communauté internationale
donc tout à l'heure on parlait
d'américanisation bien sûr on n'est pas
dans une Américaine de la police en
revanche la France étant un état de
droit elle est soumise à un certain
nombre de conventions internationales
qu'elle a négocié ratifié souverainement
et qui lui impose le respect de droit à
la vie ne serait-ce que ça et
dans le cas de l'Examen périodique
universel qui se passe tous les 5 ans
tous les États du monde s'y soumettent
elle est passée le 1er mai au Conseil
des droits de l'homme des Nations unies
sur ce sujet là et il est ressorti que
la communauté internationale les autres
États sont très inquiets sur la façon
dont les policiers font usage de la
force policier les gendarmes en France
beaucoup d'États et des États qui sont
nos partenaires démocratie libérales etc
ce sont inquiétés de ça et on fait des
recommandations à la France pour un
meilleur contrôle de la police
incontrôler l'impersal pour un
encadrement plus strict pour une
meilleure formation des policiers etc
donc il y a un véritable sujet et il y a
aussi un sujet qui monte qui est un
sujet autour de la formation des jeunes
recrues aux billets qui peuvent avoir
des pieds de stéréotypes et des préjugés
qui peuvent faire que ils interprètent
des situations tout à l'heure en parler
d'interprétation de la situation de
stress qui interprète des situations
face à des populations qui sont
d'origine maghrébine ou noire et qui se
disent et ce qui se disent bon ben là je
suis dans une situation de danger parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les codes parce qu'ils
ont été pas assez formés et parce que
ils sont très jeunes alors je dirais
jamais que la police est raciste ça
c'est sûr en revanche comme dans tout
institution il y a du racisme il y a du
racisme dans toutes les institutions
parce que le racisme existe il faut le
combattre et je pense que le
gouvernement en a pleinement conscience
est-ce que Sonia fi il y a une sorte je
retiens le mot déni face à donc ce que
vous appelez violence policière
illégitime on est on est bien d'accord
est-ce qu'il y a un digne non non je
m'inscris un faux évidemment sur ces
propos il n'y a aucun déni puisque nous
avons déjà un contrôle interne qui est
assez puissant avec l'Inspection
générale de la police nationale un
contrôle par nos pères sous autorité des
magistrats puisqu'on est dans une
enquête judiciaire la plupart du temps
doubler d'une enquête administrative qui
est donc un contrôle hiérarchique donc
on a ce double contrôle à cela se
rajoute les contrôles d'instance
extérieur comme le contrôleur de la
Défenseur des droits comme les
parlementaires qui viennent
régulièrement dans nos locaux comme
différentes organisations ONG etc donc
plus un contrôle social et sociétal qui
est important parce que nous le nous
vivons au cœur de la population et nous
sommes pas à part de la population à
laquelle nous ressemblons extrêmement ce
que nous sommes issus de ce corps civil
et c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs toute
notre particularité et nous sommes vos
arguments sauf qu'il y a cette
perception et là on en vient à la
question des refus d'obtempérer de la
défiance entre les une partie de la
jeunesse et la police on peut pas la
nier cette et donc alors je veux bien
que ce soit seulement les jeunes qui se
fassent des idées mais pardon quoi
cette défiance mais on est complètement
d'accord que la défiance existe dans ce
sens où il faut et c'est notre travail
de changer les perceptions et tous nous
devons changer nos perceptions on le
voit bien que nous avons tous des
billets cognitifs sur sur tout un tas de
sujets donc notre travail et c'est le
travail de la formation je vous
entendais parler de la formation mais
les policiers sont formés sur l'usage de
l'arme dès la formation initiale ils
sont formés
ils sont formés sur le les la lutte
contre les discriminations sur la
manière de se présenter aux citoyens
donc oui bien sûr au même titre que
n'importe quel citoyen d'ailleurs avec
ceci en plus d'aviser que comme il
dispose de cette violence de ce monopole
de la violence légitime et bien il doit
pouvoir l'utiliser à bon escient et avec
rigueur la plus absolue Loïc Hervé on va
terminer sur ce cette recrudescence des
refus de d'obtempérer là aussi les
chiffres sont vraiment impressionnants
depuis quoi une une douzaine d'années
enfin ça remonte pas être même peut-être
à un peu plus loin comment vous
l'expliquer ça
c'est la manifestation de de tendance
sociologique extrêmement fort dans la
société française de remise en cause de
l'autorité de la relation à l'uniforme
dans bien des des territoires de notre
département de notre nation dans bien
des endroits où cette question-là est
une forme de remise en cause vous savez
depuis les années 70 c'est énormément de
corps intermédiaires structurant la
société sont effondrées les uns après
les autres et en fait cette culture
commune du respect de celui qui était le
maître le curé le médecin le maire le
policier ou le gendarme qui était des
éléments de
assez répandu dans la société française
en fait n'existe quasiment plus sauf
dans un certain nombre de milieux plutôt
privilégiés ou cette tradition là sont
maintenues comme des éléments quasi
identitaires
est-ce qu'il y a parfois je dis bien
parfois des torts partagés alors je
crois qu'il y a des alors d'abord moi je
crois pas du tout la violence systémique
dans la police ou la gendarmerie je
crois que c'est valable au niveau des
chefs comme au niveau de la hiérarchie
la plus proche du terrain il y a
vraiment une idée de que la le recours à
la violence est une extrémité et dès le
début d'un échec donc ça je j'y crois
absolument pas je crois qu'il y a des
comportements violents individuels
d'ailleurs cependant peut-être devant un
comportement individuel extrême qui a
entraîné la la mort d'un jeune
évidemment on le verra en revanche je
pense qu'il y a encore des des
améliorations de la formation qui sont
des normes et qui sont très importants
je ne comprends pas qu'on arrive
toujours aujourd'hui à avoir des
policiers ou des jambes qui tutoient les
personnes qu'ils ont en face de lui ça
je le sais je l'ai dit à de très
nombreuses entreprises je comprends non
plus par exemple qu'on promette dans un
commissariat ou une
brigade de gendarmerie à des gens qu'on
leur qu'on leur propose une main gauche
le dépôt d'une main courante la main
courante n'existe pas en droit en France
on le dit on le répète et moi dans ma
vie du parlementaire régulièrement
je me suis fait agresser je vais les
gendarmerie ah bah on me dit de déposer
une main propre parce qu'une plainte
vous comprenez ah elle sera elle sera
elle sera pas suivi de de de de suite
fait dalle ça c'est très grave parce que
ça veut dire que le citoyen ne croit
plus à l'institution qui doit entendre
et prendre en charge les choses donc en
fait on a des éléments d'amélioration
assez significatif dans la police ou la
gendarmerie merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat et je vois votre
frustration vous direz agir mais le
débat est terminé à bientôt sur sur
Public Sénat merci beaucoup des d'y
avoir participé